the film takes place at this Christmas
party where things are going wild and
and the everything's just off the hook
and so that means that they have extras
in the background who are constantly
doing insane things while you're trying
to perform how's that really going to
act and remember your line and some of
these extras where they did it they told
all the background artists just go
insane do anything you want just party
the hardest you can silently and so
Olivia Munn saw because they have to be
quiet while we're doing the dialogue so
that we can get the dialogue clean and
so we Olivia Munn and I looked over and
there is this girl sitting on a filing
cabinet and this guy had his head in
between her legs which imagine that
awkward conversation where he's like no
trust me we'll get on camera more and
she's like okay I guess they decide to
improvise but what they didn't realize
is that you have to do the same thing in
a movie four hours 12 hours I think
around hour six both of them very much
regretted that decision how many hours
do you really think he had to have his
head I think 12 hours five days a week
yeah months Wow Wow because it all takes
place in one night right pretty great
bad but it's really weird to do the
dialogue while people are dancing
silently behind you it's the most
surreal party that you can overhear I'll
show you here coming you pour come come
you'll act as extras in the movie come
on quickly quickly we don't have time
it's television
[Applause]
okay okay all right thanks so much for
doing this so now they were just gonna
party and dance behind us and let's
finish the interview okay and this year
this is your demonstration of how
difficult it is to do your job I have to
tell you I'm suddenly liking my show a
lot
[Applause]
please keep it going I love this this
should be the new show Andy you could
work as being the Natalie that's waters
are completely silent we were doing this
and it was like a his story and we were
talking about something really hey yeah
and important you know it's Earl Arbor
let's talk about the fact that often
times we need a common enemy to affect
social change
now progressive white men know what it's
like to be a minority in this country
yeah and I think as a whole key part in
and as a whole we are this gentleman
right here is doing so little but at the
same time so much
[Applause]
you guys if you guys see how hard this
was I was just I would say we are
progress and our enemy is the President
of the United States what are you
talking about fantastic god totally
distracted I don't care how hard it is
to make people laugh we have a clip here
and I believe this is where you were
actually is this clip without dancing
please keep the dancing going this is a
work your resume come help them
alright you help them out here's a clip
from office Christmas party take a look
[Applause]
say you won't make budget cuts
everybody's gonna get a bonus or a
[Music]
[Applause]
yourself I know it took nine years of
crap we got Carol you know he's turning
blue
yeah our family you got a chat
[Applause]
to open
and I'm the shy guys party
[Applause]
Christmas party is in theaters this
Friday and it's gonna heal the nation
watch DJ hosts the Critics Choice Awards
this Sunday helping you lop your way
through the weekend certain on A&E TJ
Miller and his backup death
[Applause]
you